Oprah doesn't determine our taste in
literature what Oprah does is inspire
many hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people to read Oprah does
not tell every member of American
society you must read this book what
Oprah does is say I love this book and
you all should read it
so people who like Oprah read the book
and I think that's amazing because it
I love reading and I love there's
nothing better than to hear from
somebody you trust or like a
recommendation you know someone who
takes the book and presses it into your
hand and says oh this is the most
beautiful book you've got to read this
book you know that's a book I want to
read then and that's what Oprah's doing
you know Oprah's um audience is huge and
and they're very loyal and they trust
her and they love her and and when Oprah
reads a book and feels passionate about
it you know she goes on the air and she
talks about it and says you read it you
know and people do I don't I don't think
she is arbiter of taste in America I
think that's um kind of snarky cynical
way to look at what Oprah has done I I
think that that anybody who gets people
to read should be celebrated I believe
JK raw I think that every parent every
parent in the in America should send JK
Rowling a check you know for a dollar
every month as a thank-you for getting
their kids to read I mean that is
amazing
you know the Harry Potter Harry Potter
was the first book my nephew read I mean
and it's this thick you know
when I was a kid no kid was reading a
book that thick and then
waiting for the next that thick version
of it to come out I mean it's amazing it
was a real profound impact on our
culture that Harry Potter had with kids
a whole generation of kids
thanks to JK Rowling grew up loving to
read and that's kind of how I feel about
Oprah's Book Club I mean the more people
who read the better because reading it's
not like watching TV it's not like being
online watching videos and it's not like
listening to music you know it's not
better or worse it's just different and
it's important that it not be forgotten
it's a thrilling experience because you
create the movie in your mind